I do believe that was in my group we
start first with the ethical and moral
implication and we've been designing
toward human dignity
rather than designed just to do it for
the sake of technology boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake on super-pumped to be
talking about the future of the brain we
have dr. Newton Howard joining us on the
show hello thank you so much for coming
on the show I'm super excited for this
it was great being there yesterday for
the talk that you were giving and it was
very cool learning more about your work
and I'm excited to be able to share it
with our audience for those that don't
know dr. Newton Howard is a brain and
cognitive scientist the former director
of the MIT mind machine project he is a
professor of computational neuroscience
and functional neurosurgery at the
University of Oxford where he directs
the Oxford computational neuroscience
laboratory he is also the director of
MIT synthetic intelligence lab the
founder of the Center for Advanced
Defense studies and the chairman of the
brain sciences foundation you can find
all of Newton's links below including
his website Newton Howard comm ni200
comm as well as his LinkedIn profile
Newton let's start things off with one
of our favorite questions to ask our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world we live in an
interesting time where basically we have
to re-examine where we put in our
resources and the allocation of these
resources will then guide and govern
what is the next chapter of our history
of our existence may or may not totally
agree with all the way of how we
allocating this at this time to the
extent possible I believe that more
allocation should be toward things that
prevent our Clyde was
our an evident and eventual and non
avoidable fate of this planet becoming
absolutely a lot more science ought to
be directed in that focus and lest worth
trying to create more conflicts in the
name of eradicating conflicts yep
okay I was going to ask you about where
to optimally allocate the resources that
you wanted uh how you wanted to see our
trajectory move in that direction but
you gave the example of us being having
more sustainable mentality about our own
planet is that kind of the essence yes
okay yes they the direction that we
going right now assumes the existence of
this resources forever taken for granted
everything that we have on the surface
of this planet and inevitably ignore the
fact that we may have to have a
replacement in the not-too-distant
future a few hundred thousand years or
it's not a long time in human existence
so as to be starting planning for it now
and accounted for it now not just when a
crisis erupted it's unacceptable that
meteorites would be on a course of
collision Terrace and nobody noticed it
and it escaped somebody's radar in this
time that we live in it points to a
fallacy or something wrong in the way
we're directing our resources mm-hmm and
then what would be some of the more
optimal resource allocation
methodologies that we could pursue at
the private level at the governmental
level which levels and how would we
allocate the resources to these efforts
and I'm naturally biased to things that
enhances us as human that gives us the
faculty that we lost and make it make us
better at what we were on existence for
and seeing that that this augmentation
would also come out at a price of
science an allocation of which direction
do I put things into the brain research
that I put things into space research I
put things into you know static AI or
synthetic AI what's most optimal is very
soft increasing the intelligence of us
towards that sustainability okay
interesting so it might not even be just
financially figuring out where to funnel
money but it's working we also galvanize
our own intellect and time and the types
of thing right and not you know the
financial allocation isn't necessarily
just the predicament that we're solving
for but the intrinsic drive that would
govern these financial allocations and
other allocation our resources our time
our focus our surrounding that
influences rft genetic epigenetics and
so forth and then where do you think
that all of the indigenous cultures that
are currently making it clear to humans
that are living in Metropolis is about
this disconnection that we have from
source this disconnection that we have
from nature from what sustains us where
do you think that fits into all of the
issues that we have in our society today
there's a good effort from a lot of lots
of communities and people and
individuals and organizations to make
back this connection
that is lost but not fully detached
through awareness through realizing what
is it that we are missing what has gone
wrong where did we depart and then make
that turn back into these points and
correct them so that we can actually
have a better utilization of our
resources including the human energy and
the human capital it's one of the most
common ones for us is that literally
just connect more we have this just
beautiful ambience around us right now
recording this interview outdoors and
the breaths of air and the drinks of
water and the bites of food all these
things are reminders for us that that
this planet sustains us and that we need
to treat it like it sustains us and that
to remember that when children grew up
in Metropolis is that they don't
necessarily get to connect to the cosmos
cuz they can't see them but due to the
light pollution they go to the grocery
store exchange of a sheet of paper for
an Apple they don't know how the Apple
got there so these are critical
processes in remembering what sustains
us and this ties that to the
sustainability that you're mentioning
you need indeed now Newton it's probably
one of the most important things that we
do in the future is to make sure that we
understand what's actually happening
inside of our brains inside of our
bodies at large including our hearts and
all of our major organs but especially
our brain is so important and actually
it's probably one of the most beautiful
parts of the evolutionary trajectory is
this nervous system that's able to take
in these inputs make sense of these
inputs and then make decisions in the
environment that it's in teach us about
kind of like that evolutionary
trajectory of the brain what got you
hooked into being fascinated with it and
then what you're up to now so
interesting that you
put it that way because when I think
about the investigation of where is the
mind it brings me to the thought that a
referal is Plato and Aristotle inquire
into this and finally reconciled to that
it exists in the brain in the gut and in
the heart and recently a lot of the
literature and the scientific
discoveries are pointing to where these
receptor sites are located that do the
majority of the neurotransmitters and
whatnot and they you know the location
is in fact in the heart and the gut in
the brain my particular interest in this
area and the work that I focus on is
that I assume I start with assumption
that the human brain was at a level of
perfection that surpassed what we have
today and that through time through
protein misfolding through dialectic
misfolding through evolution whatever
other things that we make tributes had
degenerated we became essentially less
intelligent than where we were our
faculties are lower in capacity than it
was and from this assumption I asked
myself what can I do to compensate and
bring back what is missing and that led
me to the concept of brain prosthetics
not just bring prosthetics in the sense
that it only solves for the disease or
the broken brain but is also brain
augmentation that naturally brings back
the capacity and the things that were
lost through time
so
now
would then the natural course of the
evolution of the nervous system over
time be then the natural courses the
degeneration then of it towards the end
of its lifecycle essentially what we see
in our normal living in a normal
existence that the person has the age
their faculty most worth generation
obviously the the extreme case is the
neurodegenerative diseases or disorders
and the lower level is just the
cognitive decline that comes with age
but not that in nature it's compensated
by a level of plasticity that that
actually corrects for some of that but
not to the level where faculty is
augmented and to the extent that we
would like it to see so in the offering
that my team and I have been working on
we were able to actually come up with
these type of devices that we hope to be
the next generation prosthetic and brain
augmentation devices okay so we have
methodologies to return the nervous
system more towards youthful homeostatic
capacity without prosthetics these
generalities things of eating healthy
sleeping enough exercising these things
can get us longer longevity and more
healthier cognitive capacities during
each day these types of things and over
the lifetime yet even then we still
get old with age and have degeneration
at the end and so to be able to make
then so then the next step is then we
need to make the prosthetics right we
need to preserve life preserve that that
Minds creative capacity to continue
engaging with its family and its
community and its in the world and
building more and creating more as it
gets a ages more in it gets wiser
potentially and is able to contribute
better okay okay great
it is it is essentially like
metaphorically assumed that the aged
human is like a collection of books in a
library and in the case of Alzheimer
that library is getting burned torch
down with all the content and experience
and the knowledge would we want to
actually just sit and watch that happen
and do nothing about it in the state of
an investigative state of science today
was finished in relation to that
disorder for example some companies had
given up on trying to find remedies or
cure some companies just settled for a
lower level way to compensate for the
decline of cognition or cognitive
decline until such time that is no
longer these remedies work that's
inadequate they have got to be better
solutions they have got to be better
compensators and that's where
actually focused and moving in that
direction what a profound analogy that
the library is being burned these pages
are being torn out you can't find what's
written on the pages as easily all these
things the associative web is becoming
worse and worse degrading interesting
yeah and how important is it to our
especially our closest ones our loved
ones and our families and our friends
and our relationships that we want to
preserve those books of life experience
of wisdom of creative capacity
throughout life and and be able to you
know parse them and identify what were
those key aspects of people's lives and
that's that's such a profound importance
of of this endeavoring now okay so now
have them the last how long have you
been then working on putting together
these prosthetics and yet teach us about
that the themes so I I started my
scientific journey focusing on
essentially human agency and a sense of
self and looking at the modeling of
human intention more in the
computational sense and then I spent the
majority of my early life and career
working as a government officer in the
intelligence community and subsequently
at some point in time I have an
awakening to what I can do outside of
that space and I decided to look at
where these apparatus are being
fabricated where it's being produced
essentially an asset of consciousness
which is the brain
so that journey would date back to early
2000 late 90s all the way to when I
finished my study in Oxford and the the
2014 and creating part of the study into
looking at these prosthetics from
various aspects from the material
science to the application layer to the
analytics it is a hardware design and so
forth
so collectively it's an ongoing journey
of about 20 years worth of work that led
to a substantial amount of design
material actual prototypes certain
aspects of application life patience of
the therapeutic of the actual therapies
itself the lab in Oxford is attributed
to a large number of clinical
interventions in Parkinson and in other
disorders can exceed in access of 900
patients I've benefitted from some of
these therapeutics effect in tertiary
interventions the actual technology in
the form factor that we would like it to
be I still an ongoing work in progress
that is likely to be available on the
market within the next 2 months or so 20
years this is 2 decades since in the
space just sponging up the edge of the
fields and wanting and synthesizing
figuring out your role in the equation
and and also wanting to to go out and
and make make impact at the level of
what can be seen with our with our
families with these closest ones to us
when we see that someone has Parkinson's
was one of the nura Jenner diseases that
you listed and that what therapeutic
benefits can we create that can
almost immediately be seen to make us
live healthier and wanting to get that
done as quickly and efficiently as
possible
yeah again it just brings me to what you
were saying at the beginning that if we
can have are these these libraries that
we have within us if we can have
additional books gets stored and
synthesized with what's in the existing
library
who knows what unique new creative novel
thoughts could come if we can more
sustainably keep ourselves longer now
let's talk about this technology so this
is the most recent endeavoring it's been
900 over 900 now patients in the the
thick it's for the therapy for
Parkinson's for deep brain stimulation
other Parkinson deep brain stimulation
on Parkinson's ok so right now we do
both non-invasive brain stimulation and
we do invasive yes brain stimulation so
yeah so let's let's talk about those two
and then let's talk about how you are
doing this in basically how you're
identifying the target how you're
implanting your technology and what it's
doing if your so the the world of brain
machine interfaces brain computer
interfaces and DBS which is deep brain
stimulation it fits into two categories
they they Savannah non-invasive the
invasive basically uses tools and
methodologies and surgery functional
neurosurgery like craniotomy and
craniofacial insertion which requires
the opening of the brain and getting
into layers of the cortex that are
relatively intrusive the non-invasive
class which is like tDCS TMS and so
forth and many trans magnetic
stimulation direct current stimulation
these are passive they don't penetrate
the cortex to the level that
we hope for therefore you can't get the
therapeutic effect for all the different
things or indications that you hope for
our technology at the moment fits within
the class of the intrusive or semi
intrusive intervention was the direction
towards non intrusive technology we
refer to it as patching and one up the
this one is in the horizon the current
one that is ready to be deployed it's a
system that we refer to as the NOAA
system which is made out of Aquila chip
and two fundamental layers of
architecture one is referred to as FCU
fundamental code unit I want to refer to
as the VC which is the brain code the
fundamental code unit is an analytical
framework that essentially leads us to
understand the inquiries between neurons
and the communication in our inner
communication in exchange communication
between neurons thereby allowing us to
do the clinical intervention at the
computational element that's what being
conveyed rather than you know the
general flush of the intervention for
the electrophysiology or the electro
activity of the brain or the chemical
activities of the brain which is also
someone what's exist as a state of the
art today it also allows us to intervene
not only an electrical fashion but also
using the power of light or up to
genetics the techniques of optogenetics
is we marry a protein segment to the
specific neuron thereby activating what
we would refer to as neuron sites and
causing this neuron to before the
receptive and when it becomes
photoreceptors and ignorant
in honor of state and by changing this
functional structure we're able to halt
the disease or modify essentially the
programming of that particular zone so I
hope the technical level is adequate for
the audience but the way I explain it is
more like putting the capacity of your
house to receive the electrical signal
electrical of the grid or light of the
Sun and then then in house a lot of
things can happen as a result of these
capabilities the the structure of the
world when it comes to the neuronal
world essentially is that you have a
structure brain you know the actual
neuronal structure and the normal
function and together exhibits the
behavior in outside world we want to
modify this behavior in outside world by
affecting the function layer the
functional layer and since really the
structural there is something that we
don't want to manipulate that much as
that's his old method okay so we are
doing fMRI or eg first to find this area
of the brain that we need to target yes
okay yes so when you when the first
level of intervention is to reach a
level of diagnosis and perhaps before
the clinical diagnosis is reached so in
the case of Parkinson you can discover
it as early as twenty seven twenty one
years and
in the earlier you discover these
disorders the more likely you're able to
do something that can correct or slow
down the disease it's always interesting
thinking about how we haven't had the
full connectome yet of the brain fully
mapped out in all of its nuanced neural
architecture as well as
neurotransmission that occurs and yet we
are going in there and that in itself is
like well how do we you know get that
done the connectome done in the full
understanding of neural transmission and
then so then you your ID okay so you
you're identifying the area that needs
in the therapeutic and then you have
what is this what is the style of
process to it what are what are we sure
yes what are we putting in and yeah and
how are we doing it so they once the it
is discovered that this person is for
example receive the clinical diagnosis
of Parkinson and that the actual
procedure is appropriate for them
meaning that they're good you know
the pair of good health otherwise that
can handle the surgery like craniotomy
or kind of facial where is the QE
technology you're able to intervene at
craniofacial intervention or surgical
technique the surgical thing that you
can use because it's a smaller size and
you essentially use this passageway to
insert a device about 1.9 by 2 point 2
millimeter in size which is roughly
about the grain of rice into the zone
that has been implicated in the case of
Parkinson that would be the subhanak
nucleus or SCN in the basal ganglia and
you drive the Kiwi device chip into that
area it is then
made of material called carbon nanotubes
that a neurons start basically gathering
around their area and growing it then
sends this growth of neurons or the
presence of these neurons start
modulating electrophysiological a
modulation pattern that is fit to stop
the tremor which is the most immediate
thing that we want to stop so this new
modulation happens by post generation
essentially at a very very low power
there are two other therapeutic effects
or engagement that takes place one we
refer to as a scaffolding effect and the
second is or the third there would be
the optogenetics in event that that's
what we want to do is choose regrowing
cells or reprogramming the functional
area in this projection zone the system
has the capability of communicating this
data outside of the brain to a nearby
device we referred to as the propagator
and then the propagator is able to
convey or connect this information to a
system on a cloud that is essentially a
full scale referred to as a brain
operating system that is capable of
processing this data generating
additional inferences or Corrections or
modification to the firmware or to the
software and then following the same
path for a backward again to back into
the chip that process continues on for
the life of the therapy we do
inductively charging so that it's a
chronic device we do not have to go back
and take out unless there's some serious
clinical malfunction or malfunction
electronic malfunction of the device
which is all to be determined and worked
out in the future tests before we
actually go into the first
a patient with this full encapsulation
all Parkinson's is basal ganglia issue
in that area Parkinson is a complex
disorder but it maps to essentially the
dopamine secretion and the vesicles the
secretes dopamine is not working
optimally and there is additional
explanation to the causality of what
causes that to happen in the first place
first order effect and whatnot and we're
essentially treating it when it became
when it becomes absolutely instead of 21
years yeah ahead of time yeah yeah yeah
and then then the the neural prosthetic
size of a grain of rice then what how is
that fabricated at that smaller size to
be able to connect to neurons inside of
and how does it connect to neurons how
does it do the optogenetics for the
therapeutic effect sure the system is
made of a system on a chip a system on a
chip was connected to the CNT chip the
CMT chip and the system ownership is
community his radio element in a battery
element and altogether actually is
fabricated of material that is unique
and to shrink it to that size of a
package is being quite an engineering
challenge that we still working aspects
of it but our target size is
approximately 1.9 by two point two
millimeter my goodness yeah I'm just
imagining the smallest tiniest little
tweezer hands just that was what surgery
yeah that's Rick in that surgery yet
that's trying to put together all these
complex pieces Wow yeah and then you
explain the inductive charging and then
the so there's there's also compares
communication then that happens it's
able to then touch
this is tens of thousands of neurons or
humbie we're targeting or our goal is a
million we are targeting in this next
one approximately ten thousand we are
now at about a few thousands and it has
a level of sophistication of
reconfiguring some of those channels and
sensing what it's touching
unprecedented Leon Denny capabilities
that has been expressed so far sensing
what it's touching I was thinking about
that as upon entry I was envisioning
this forest yeah oh yeah and then it's
okay let's say you put like a in an
actual force you put a bigger grain of
rice into a forest yeah and then it just
touches all of the leaves right and then
the eye doesn't quite know what it's
touching at entry yeah this is so then I
was imagining that there is some sort of
a like upon entry that there's some sort
of a dislike linking process of oh I
know what I'm touching how to stimulate
it how to do the therapeutic effects and
that's like how does that this system
carries onboard intelligence in in
software that's a NOAA system we which
is stands for neurons on augmented human
and it essentially is made out of these
various modules there is onboard and
these modules sense and position this
neurons in space and figure out you know
as it is touching the tail or the front
or the middle or so forth and then
assign did you know what is the
modulation pattern that is going to be
reduced into the into this projection
zone so these sensors are at like the
scale of like a micron a micron yeah so
so at the micron level it's like little
micron hitting like hairs or little coal
vesicles yeah
and there that's able to decipher what
part of the neuron it's yeah yeah and
Wow any hopefully 10,000 on this next
one
yeah be as we as we're clearing out the
or debugging the first scale then we we
keep increasing the order of complexity
but the target is about a million and
the actual device is engineers such that
you can actually put in the brain a
number of greater let's say greater than
ten devices can actually be inserted
into one human brain without causing any
damage so then there's a process of
processing the signals that you're
getting and then then there's a also a
process of that tiny little grain of
rice being able to communicate what is
reading yet to through locations and
close to but to the cloud the cloud yeah
okay for lots of computational power to
understand do it and then there's a
close loop to it distributes that that
into the holes what to do yeah and then
then the device then will say okay so
then that means that this area is my
target this aspect and this is where I
need to apply the optogenetics and then
yeah but you said there was a process of
you need to make the cells
photoreceptive yes
so here is the process where we
basically introduce the antivirus to
allow that genetic therapy to actually
take place there is a process to
identify the number of connects there is
a process to choose the appropriate
therapy this basically going up the
stack all the way to the cloud and back
to the device again that's a process
where the system is lining and
depositing some of the information is
being collected real-time and near
real-time but most of the intervention
is taking place
on the device directly real-time because
it carries the system-on-chip
so it's capable of executing certain
courses of action that is already being
pre-scripted
if you will okay
and the the virus that's applied makes
the neurons photoreceptive then then you
apply the therapeutic effects of the
ogden etics and then after a period of
how long does the virus then leave the
six months that it was in less than six
months of sustainability and Riaan
Jackson's you can actually reach the
therapeutic effect okay six months of of
so six months of I can I would what I
feel do the blue they've no they will
never you don't feel any negative object
but you do you ever feel like
optogenetic do I have what I ever feel
like my within my basal ganglia that
this is absolutely feel the tremor
effect is gone your two positive effects
and interesting so then foods rather
than a tremor effect occurring I would I
wouldn't feel I where there would be a
tremor fact it would be key to avoid it
out yet but interesting and then with
but with thin I'm just trying to imagine
something in my basal ganglia making it
so that I don't feel the tremor effect
okay and what that would feel like well
it's it's it's like a person on ADHD who
was extremely hyper and all of a sudden
they take their medication and they feel
so relaxed and calm it's almost was
almost like that feeling or a person who
is you know you will Parkinson Parkinson
have a very ugly sight to it where you
all sudden become like a child again
you're not able to to plan your motion
you're not able to control your
cognitive capacity other other faculties
and other
psychotic also behaviors the you you
essentially benefit from seeing all
these things gone
and over time completely eliminated once
the therapy is in effect and the
regrowth takes place and a
electrophysiology bacteremia status they
go back to normal you can't focus you
can focus on bigger things of being a
human right and if you you know wherever
you whatever you were at the elevation
of knowledge you're able to climb back
to that elevation and then be there
and then climb further rather than
crashing Brian like I said in the
Illinois heimer
which is inevitably the state that we
are in today and it's beautifully said
and then it's important to point that
when when we do tag some of these
neurons and address the corrections it's
not that it's gonna statically stay
there forever there is a process of
Genesis that and motion that happens
where things actually change but when
you change there is a corrected next
generation that came into that place
which is important to see happening in
the zone of projection that was once L
and now it's cured and has a new neurons
growing it will essentially will
essentially have new neurons if the
intervention happens at a at a time when
this completely deaths of neurons then
you won't have that if the intervention
comes earlier then the stem cells and
the ability to grow ways
this is why identifying this with that
thank you should 21 years in advance
yeah yeah
while the stem cells are still able to
then do their neurogenesis that's okay
cool when we had to design a tech form
for the measurement of activity was
doing really living that actually are
wearable it's an essential earbud that
allows us that should do this detection
and help aid the physician to do the
diagnosis as early as possible because
it will do the measurement during the
time that you're making coffee or are
you having breakfast or you you know or
your normal day of work so that you're
capable of actually recognizing this
this consequential indicators and soon
is just computer vision occurring in the
background and watching that yeah
movement yeah okay and the biometrics
constantly being these things up and
analyzed yeah now what's what's next in
the trajectory of this you have okay
it's Parkinson's it's it's it's trying
to democratize that more around the
world to help people and then also it's
other neurodegenerative yeah identifying
other biomarkers for neuro degeneration
and trying to go in there and make
augmentation and then is there also a
map a roadmap for neuro augmentation at
large for even someone that may be a you
know 15 or 25 year older and then you
were also teaching me this in the
yesterday about potentially just being
able to have this as a patch instead of
an invasive yeah take us down this road
so you you you you you kind of like to
to go down that path you'd have to
imagine a different world today we
depend on an iphone on PDAs computers
all of these devices as an aid for
computation and as a way to learn
language as a way to
facilitate new information and whatnot
well this imagine a world where this
type of interventions or this type of
needs are not needed you you you think
of a question and the question is
queried or searched or done and
offloaded directly into your visual
cortex and then it's all happening
within your brain so your eyes is doing
the search your thoughts is being a
query your text query essentially and
then your brain is projecting that
information and it's all happening that
would enable you to do photo reading
that would enable you to download new
language I have an application that it
does whatever you want it to do well the
path to that is essentially
understanding the details that's in the
brain in the pathways I'm being able to
capture and learn these pathways so that
we can actually have a patch device that
hacks its way back at the risk of using
the word hacking and using the entire
nervous system collectively as a whole
this future that you're imagining of us
being able to download a little sdk of a
language or a the cutting edge of
mathematics or it's such an interesting
world wouldn't I want all of it and then
just have it all and store to access at
any point make all these associations in
the web yes and
and when we all have access to that then
then that's the civilizations of
knowledge fully democratized accessible
with thought absolutely and that's this
flow of instead of meat sticks yes
yeah the limitation the limitation is
essentially imposed by how fast he
typing by you know think of the moving
from the wire speed to your thoughts
speed would I be as greedy as saying I
want to download 50 languages to my head
a hundred languages the entire set of
languages was known to humankind yes I
would and it is it set a fundamental
belief of those who want to actually
make the machine have this capability
versus those who want the brain to have
this capability
I believe the computing power needed it
sits in that box that we all carry the
brain with all its affiliation the gut
and heart and so forth is being able to
actually tap into this hidden resources
and into this computing power and into
these gates and into this peripheral
system and and have it work
the way it was intended to at some point
in evolution that's the key
differentiator between my school of
thought and that of some of others that
are actually approaching the brain
machine interface problem
so it may be that the this ultimate
evolutionary trajectory of our species
on this rock the next step is to treat
the brain that gut the heart as gates of
opening that portal up so that we can
have this free flow of civilizations and
knowledge of a back and forth through
from us and through it rather than the
appendages and yes these are externally
inside of us yes so the sort of speed of
creativity and all that stuff it's just
communication that's just it just
becomes a it it seems frightening to
some but it is what is beyond GX xxx is
it in a transmission speed if you will
do we even need these wires do we even
need this ether connection it might be
something even faster than that and we
won't know until we actually explore
these areas and I expect that we will
see this eventualities was in ten to
fifty years so it's not a significant
period of time for that
and to do it with a great amount of
ethics yes and morality and philosophy
embedded with all of these brilliant
neuro engineers and neuro designers
nerado mentors can we get these right
philosophers and ethicists and moral
scientists working alongside them and
especially geopolitically and we make it
for peace and for creativity or
collaboration but also we you know
compete to get there but in a way that
is collaborative and yes yeah it's such
a critical component okay yeah going to
our first question is do I take this
capability and make it available and
only available to augment soldiers or do
I democratize it that make it available
to everybody it's starting with those
who are afflicted with the worst
conditions like neurodegenerative
disorders and whatnot preserving our
libraries preserving our heritage
restoring human dignity that's what
brings it back to your initial question
is the importance of this reallocation
of resources the doesn't start from the
budget table from the capital investment
it starts from our own conscience Drive
intention to guide it in a particular
direction today there's a lot of work in
that area and support in that area that
comes from military organizations DARPA
an ESD etc various programs like that
with others are following it in that
direction sometime you know sadly
without questioning the ethical and
moral implication I do believe that was
in my group we start first with the
ethical and moral implication and we've
been designing toward human dignity
rather than designed just to do it for
the sake of technology excellent yes
that ethos is so strong in you and then
that resonates with others that are able
to also realize that and carry that
forth as the first principle yeah a
couple quick ones on the way out Newton
um you mentioned that the consciousness
being the seat within the the evolution
of the heart gut brain that that
sentience arise through that process
there's also so many other spiritual
leaders that say that that that we come
from the source and that we take our
seat of consciousness intentionally in
these bodies to experience specific
lessons on this school of earth what are
your thoughts about that I think that we
were all correct in the way we
describing it it's the description is
coming from the journey of where we're
coming from so each one perceives it in
a slightly different narrative but the
collective narratives is the agreement
that exists the conscience and whether
we want it to be a conscience that it's
pure and reasonable and fit it to word
being able to accept the larger things
that you know sits ahead of us is it
journey into the Stars is it journey
into consciousness in itself it always
it all starts with trying to understand
with ace consciousness what is
intelligence where is the seat of the
soul and it brings it back again to a
question that has been asked thousands
of years ago and we still don't have a
definitive answer do we need a
definitive answer or is the journey
itself the questions and along the way
are the important part
mmm power in that question along the way
in the journey and Newton how about are
we in a simulation we could be we could
be
yeah I couldn't give narratives on the
top of that and what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
existence you know to be appreciative of
the beauty of existence rather than
resented and worried about the heaviness
of it and all the things that brings
plagues and psychosis just be happy you
exist fact there is something instead of
nothing
yes Wow
then thank you so much for coming on the
show teaching us about the future of the
brain thanks man
it's such a pleasure we're super
appreciative grateful thank you thank
you thank you thanks everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking also check out the links in the
bio again Newton Howard comm ni200 calm
as walls and earrings link didn't
profile check those out and have more
conversations with your friends your
families co-workers people online on
social media about the future of the
brain and about all the technologies we
talked about and preserving these
libraries and endeavoring more
creatively and also support the artists
the entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
organizations around the world that you
believe in support Newton supports
simulation our links are below - to our
patreon our cryptocurrency our PayPal
link design cool merch and get paid join
us and help us grow and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you very much for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace
this is good good job running good job